en dépit de tout ce qu'on peut dire je
crois que tu es pmp à sa place dans
l'émission de l'année puisque c'est une
émission qui ne laisse personne
indifférent quoi qu'il advienne le bad
buzz de l'année c'est ce dérapage
médiatique d'un certain gilbert rozon
qui a mis à la poubelle une partie d'une
émission n'est plus virulente du paf à
savoir la france a un incroyable talent
l'ambiance n'est pas totalement et même
[Musique]
le plus gros buzz de l'année
si quand tf1 a organisé un débat avec
les dix candidats à l'élection
présidentielle dans un décor qui
ressemblait celui du maillon faible et
je trouve ça formidable plus 10 millions
téléspectateurs alors seulement mon
meilleur souvenir d'un pmp
c'était en juin dernier c'est la
dernière de la saison et je suis tombé
dans la piscine je ne m'y attendais
absolument pas est ce que j'ai préféré
c'était la poule partie avec une
prétendante évidemment
[Applaudissements]
le meilleur chroniqueur de l'année il
n'y en a pas parce qu'il s'agit d'une
chroniqueuse c'est isabelle morini bosc
à mon avis à un personnage totalement
farfelue et c'est pour ça qu'on aime
déjà fait tomber en bout
[Applaudissements]
mon conseil à un chroniqueur actuel pour
l'année prochaine c'est matthieu
delormeau qu'ils arrêtent de se lever
constamment sur ce tabouret pour pour
exister
oui oui céline et c'est franchement
c'est bon tu entends mec calme sérénité
zen attitude
[Musique]
m